It: Chapter Two has finally hit the big screen,
and while the epic conclusion to the adaptation
of Stephen King's 1986 novel It has largely
left fans satisfied, a fair number of critics
weren't so impressed.
Fans of the original book and the films are
likely to shoot down a few of the pervasive
criticisms of the flick with these arguments.
Several changes were made to the character
of Derry Library resident Mike Hanlon and
criticisms around these changes can be confusing.
All of the Losers are bullied, but in King's
novel, Henry Bowers' bullying of Mike was
particularly awful because of Bowers' unrestrained
racism.
Some observers took issue with the fact that,
in both movies, the racist element the bullying
against Mike was substantially toned down,
leading to charges of squeamishness on the
part of director Andy Muschietti and screenwriter
Gary Dauberman.
But the racist nature of the Bowers gang's
bullying of Mike is certainly implied, if
no racial slurs are used on screen.
"Stay the f--- out of my town!"
And it's worth remembering that the films
are set 31 years later than the novel, with
Chapter One set in 1989 rather than 1958.
Racism is, of course, still pervasive today,
but it's not a huge stretch to say that the
use of overt slurs was more likely to be encountered
in the '50s than the '80s.
And neither film really suffered from the
filmmakers' decision to make the racial aspect
of Bowers' antagonism toward Mike more subtle.
The decision was the obvious byproduct not
only of the time period switch, but of adapting
a 33-year old novel.
Another difference between literary Mike and
cinematic Mike is the fate of his parents;
they were incorporated into Mike's tragic
backstory in the movies, having burned to
death inside a locked apartment while young
Mike watched helplessly.
A newspaper headline conspicuously shown in
It: Chapter Two refers to a pair of "crackheads"
who set themselves on fire in front of their
young son, but this is later revealed to be
one of Pennywise's tricks.
After the malevolent entity is defeated, the
true headline is revealed, and it's made clear
that Mike's parents actually died in an electrical
fire.
The reason for this change is fairly obvious:
For narrative reasons, the poor kid needed
a good dose of trauma.
And the fake headline plays off of the Bowers
gang's racially charged bullying.
But one spectacularly wrongheaded review by
Slate's Jack Hamilton opined that the change
itself smacked of racism.
He wrote:
"To transform the only black protagonist from
the child of responsible, nurturing parents
into the child of negligent crack cocaine
addicts is far worse than lazy writing; it's
to actively draw from a deeply racist set
of cultural tropes."
We guess he must have been yawning really
wide or looking at his watch when the true
newspaper headline was revealed.
Of all the critical gripes leveled at It:
Chapter Two, by far the most common had to
do with the film's nearly three-hour run time.
The film was labeled "arduous," "muddled,"
and "meandering."
"Why?
What is taking so long?
I wasted all day here for you!"
Of course, King's novel is more than 1,100
pages long, and a huge amount of material
was left out in bringing the story to the
screen.
Some elements were combined into details in
the films' story, such as the fire that killed
Mike's parents being a clear reference to
the novel's fire at the Black Spot, a historical
event which used to illustrate Pennywise's
centuries-long influence on Derry.
Those going into It: Chapter Two expecting
a brisk, breezily plotted ride to the final
showdown either weren't familiar with the
source material, or were expecting Dauberman
and Muschietti to take far more liberties
than they did.
The individual and collective journeys of
the Losers Club play directly into how they
deal with the horror of that final confrontation,
and if they had been given short shrift, it's
likely that many of these same critics would
have been complaining about that.
Many of It: Chapter Two's critics also took
issue with its humorous tone, in particular
the wisecracks the adult members of the Losers
Club are prone to lobbing at each other as
they prepare to face off against a horror
so unimaginable that they almost all forgot
their first encounter with It.
Much of the humor is even intertwined with
the horror, as with a brilliant visual homage
to John Carpenter's 1982 classic The Thing.
But it's clear for some of the characters,
the humor is there to mask the fear.
It's the old "whistling past the graveyard"
trope; one laughs so that they may not soil
themselves out of sheer terror.
The Losers Club is an irreverent bunch in
both the novel and the films, and the banter
doesn't just have the effect of entertaining
the audience, it also keeps them from going
insane.
If anything, the humor is even dialed down
from the book.
Perhaps the most frustrating reviews of It:
Chapter Two were those that completely whiffed
in pinpointing the film's themes.
Take, for example, this excerpt from the review
of NBC News' Noah Berlatsky:
"Chapter Two presents itself as an exploration
of nostalgia and memory.
The adults magically forget their childhood
adventures when they move away from Derry,
and the movie is about them reacquainting
themselves with their past friendships and
with their true selves upon their return."
What the Losers are reacquainting themselves
with, voluntarily or not, is the horror of
their youth - the searing, inescapable trauma
which many of us deal with, and which is often
buried not by some magic, but as a form of
emotional self-defense.
Dauberman spelled this out in an interview
with Inverse.
"I think as an adult, we all have some repressed
trauma somewhere in us.
I'm the same age as the Losers in [It: Chapter
Two].
I followed up on my own childhood, and how
easy it is for memories to fade.
Even the more traumatic ones.
Like getting details wrong, or [asking], 'Did
that happen?
When?
I can't remember.'"
The biggest bully of all
The esoteric ending of King's novel is practically
unfilmable.
The filmmakers behind It: Chapter Two offered
up their own interpretation, and of course,
many critics jumped all over it: As a monstrous
Pennywise menaces them, the Losers essentially
take away his power by ridiculing him until
he's physically small enough that they can
rip out and destroy his still-beating heart.
At least one observer came somewhat close
to the mark by stating that the Losers "sort
of bully [Pennywise] to death" during a conversation
with Muschietti, only for the director to
set him straight:
"I didn't see it as bullying so much as it
was about reversing the power of belief on
this creature, who uses belief as a weapon
to kill his victims…For the first time,
it's the Losers who have this power, and they
start telling him what he is…You're a headless
boy; you're a weak old woman.
And finally they converge on the concept of
a clown, which is just the most helpless and
powerless thing…The power of belief is Pennywise's
power, but it's also his biggest weakness."
So it is with all bullies, whose victims must
feel weak for them to feel powerful.
Pennywise is simply the biggest bully of them
all.
So once that "power of belief" is taken away,
he has nothing left.
"Losers stick together."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.